desde las calles de Ecuador hasta el
gobierno la indignación por el
feminicidio de María Belén Bernal
presuntamente dentro de una institución
policial llevó al presidente a pedir la
renuncia del ministro del interior
Patricio Carrillo y de la cúpula de las
fuerzas de seguridad
es solicitado a los
mandos poner su cargos a
rtistas presentando sobre respectivas
Bajas para evaluar su permanencia en la
institución les quiero pedir perdón
porque esto no debe suceder nunca pero
mucho menos en un edificio público donde
se forman quienes deben protegernos
los acontecimientos dan conmocionado a
un país entero María Belén Bernal fue a
visitar a su esposo un Coronel de la
policía a una escuela de la institución
en Quito desde ese mismo día el 11 de
septiembre desapareció hasta que su
cuerpo fue encontrado en las
inmediaciones del edificio con señales
de asfixia las primeras investigaciones
señalan a su esposo Germán Cáceres
prófugo desde hace días como el
principal sospechoso del feminicidio y
cuentan además que una docena de agentes
ahora bajo investigación escucharon los
gritos de auxilio de la víctima sin
hacer nada
la madre de María Belén Bernal denunció
a la policía y al estado
mi hija es una víctima ella murió dentro
de la escuela de superior superior de
policía por lo tanto es un crimen de
estado señores es un crimen de estado mi
hija no puede quedar impune No más
un grito de Justicia que desde hace días
se replica en masivas manifestaciones en
todo el país